>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, TODAY A HORRIFIC
EXPLOSION ROCKING BEIRUT,
LEBANON, KILLING DOZENS OF
PEOPLE, INJURING THOUSANDS.
HERE LIVE WITH THE VERY LATEST,
BILL
KHALID IS WITH US.
>> GOOD EVENING.
IT IS DEFINITELY A SAD NIGHT
TONIGHT.
A DISASTER IN EVERY SENSE OF THE
WORD.
THE EXPLOSION CAUSED WIDESPREAD
DAMAGE IN EVERY PART OF THE
CITY.
THE MINISTER SAID IT WAS
APPARENTLY CAUSED BY AMMONIUM
THAT WAS STORED IN THE WAREHOUSE
WAREHOUSE.
THE MINISTERS STATED AT LEAST
SEVEN TO EIGHT HAVE BEEN KILLED
AND MORE THAN 4,000 ARE WOUNDED.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE MISSING
NOW.
PEOPLE ARE ASKING THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THEIR LOVED
ONES.
THEY CAN’T SEARCH AT NIGHT
BECAUSE THERE IS NO ELECTRICITY.
WE ARE FACING A REAL CATASTROPHE
CATASTROPHE.
BEIRUT HOSPITALS TONIGHT ARE
OVERWHELMED WITH THE INSURED.
AMBULANCES ALL OVER --
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
WHAT SHE IS STAYING, BREAKING UP
THERE, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT